The series starts with Viserys Targaryen (played
by actor Paddy Considine) sitting on the Iron
Throne as the King of Westeros.
His mount - Balerion the Black Dread.
King Viserys Targaryen is chosen by the lords
of Westeros to succeed the Old King, Jaehaerys
Targaryen, at the Great Council at Harrenhal.
A warm, kind, and decent man, Viserys only
wishes to carry forward his grandfather’s
legacy.
But good men don’t necessarily make for
great kings.
The King has a famous brother about whom entire
Westeros tells stories, Daemon Targaryen,
the Rogue Prince played by an actor Matt Smith.
It's George R.R. Martin's favorite Targaryen
known as Prince of the City, Lord Flea Bottom
and the Rogue Prince.
He's the most controversial man of his lifetime,
an audacious rogue prince and adventuer who
seems made of good and evil in equal measure.
Prince Daemon is the most experienced warrior
of his time and wields the Valyrian steel
blade Dark Sister.
A dragonrider whose dragon is Caraxes.
Writings of Westerosi Archmaester gives the
best description of Daemon.
It reads: ''Over the centuries, House Targaryen
has produced both great men and monsters.
Prince Daemon was both.
In his day there was not a man so admired,
so beloved, and so reviled in all Westeros.
He was made of light and darkness in equal
parts.
To some he was a hero, to others the blackest
of villains.''
King Viserys also has a daughter, Rhaenyra
Targaryen.
She will be played by an actress Emma D'Arcy.
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, cheered as the
Realm's Delight is the first-born child of
King Viserys I Targaryen.
Rhaenyra was King Viserys I's only living
child by his first wife, Queen Aemma of House
Arryn.
At the age of eight she was made her father's
heir and grew up expecting to become the first
ruling Queen of Westeros.
Rhaenyra is a dragonrider whose mount was
Syrax.
Rhaenyra and Daemon are together despite the
fact that they are niece and uncle.
Since the King's first wife died, the King
married Alicent Hightower (she's played by
Olivia Cooke).
With her he finally gets male children, the
oldest of which is Aegon.
But still, Aegon's half sister, Rhaenyra,
is older and even though the king has male
heirs, Rhaenyra remains the official heir
to the throne.
At first young Rhaenyra and Alicent got along
well, but rift grew between them as soon as
Alicent produced her own children for Viserys
I, and clearly wanted them to succeed to the
throne instead of her.
Alicent bore Viserys I four children: Aegon
II, Aemond One-Eye, Daeron the Daring, and
Helaena (who became the sister-wife of Aegon
II).
The reason Alicent and Viserys wed was Alicent's
father, Otto Hightower (played by Rhys Ifans)
who had been Hand of the King in the last
few years of the long reign of King Jaehaerys
I Targaryen.
In 101 AC Otto brought the young Alicent to
the royal court, where she cared for the aging
king.
Jaehaerys eventually died in 103 AC while
Alicent was reading to him and was succeeded
by his grandson Viserys I.
The last, but not least of the Targaryens
from this time period, we have Princess Rhaenys
known among the smallfolk as the Queen Who
Never Was.
She is the granddaughter of Jaehaerys I Targaryen,
and the cousin of Viserys I Targaryen and
Daemon Targaryen.
As her father was the Prince of Dragonstone,
and she was his firstborn child, many considered
her as being next in line for the Iron Throne,
but upon quite a few unfortunate events, such
as the death of her father, she was passed
over.
The great council voted for her cousin Viserys
to be the new King.
Rhaenys married legendary Corlys of House
Velaryion, known as the Sea Snake who will
also play a major role in this series, and
he's played by an actor Steve Toussaint.
While the first few episodes will pretty much
be a calm before storm in which we will get
to know all these characters, the second half
of the first season will see the beginning
of the most devastating war Westeros has ever
seen - the Dance of the Dragons.
It all starts when King Viserys dies and half
of the kingdom sides with his designated heir
Rhaenyra while the other half sides with Queen
Alicent who pushes the claim of her son Aegon.
We have the Greens against the Blacks.
The Greens are the faction that support the
claim of Aegon ll Targaryen, their rivals
being the Blacks, who support the claim of
Rhaenyra Targaryen.
Both were named for the color of their clothes
worn during one tourney.
The forced closeness of Rhaenyra's and Alicent's
children increased animosity between the blacks
and the greens.
The royal children and grandchildren became
dragonriders and court visitors observed the
dragons of one faction snapping and spitting
flames at the dragons of the other party.
Viserys dies in mid-season on the third day
of third moon of 129 AC during a nap in the
Red Keep of King's Landing.
On his deathbed, he refuses to change the
succession, and decrees his heir to be Rhaenyra.
He's found dead by a servant who first goes
to Alicent to inform her of Viserys's death,
which proves to be a grave mistake as Alicent
proclaims Aegon the King over the wishes of
Viserys.
At the time of her father's death, Rhaenyra
is on Dragonstone as is the place for true
heir.
The greens in King's Landing ensure that the
news of Viserys's death does not reach Rhaenyra
until her own supporters in the Red Keep are
dead or imprisoned
and Aegon II's coronation had already occurred.
King Viserys decreed Rhaenyra to succeed him
but Aegon the Elder, the eldest son of his
second wife Alicent, is instead crowned Aegon
II by Ser Criston Cole, the Lord Commander
of the Kingsguard.
On Dragonstone, Rhaenyra learns about the
death of her father and the betrayal of her
siblings.
Rhaenyra, in answer to Aegon's betrayal is
crowned a queen at Dragonstone and swears
revenge.
This leads to a civil war between Rhaenyra
and Aegon, the Dance of the Dragons.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
The devastating civil war that tore apart
the Seven Kingdoms.
The war lasted for three years, and by the
time it came to an end thousands were dead,
nearly all of the Targaryen dragons had been
killed as well as many Targaryens themselves.
It didn't start outright with war using dragons
and armies, but at first it was a war of ravens.
Rhaenyra makes her own council at Dragonstone,
the black council.
Participants are, amongst others, her uncle-husband
Daemon, her three eldest sons Jacaerys, Lucerys
and Joffrey, Lord Corlys Velaryon, and his
wife, Princess Rhaenys.
During the council it's resolved that while
Rhaenyra remains at Dragonstone to regain
her health, Prince Daemon and Caraxes will
travel to the Riverlands, to make Harrenhal
their base and rallying point for those loyal
to Rhaenyra.
House Velaryon will close off the Gullet blocking
all shipping from Blackwater Bay.
Princess Rhaenys is convinced that Storm's
End will declare for Rhaenyra, since Lord
Boremund Baratheon, the deceased father of
Lord Borros and Rhaenys's uncle, had always
been a supporter of Rhaenys.
Prince Daemon also is convinced that Lady
Jeyne Arryn, the Maiden of the Vale, will
bring her support to their side.
Although they believe the north to be too
remote to play an important part in the war,
messages are to be sent to those lords nevertheless.
Rhaenyra's sons themselves depart to rally
the lords to heir side, with the eldest Jacaerys
visiting the Arryns of the Eyrie, the Manderlys
of White Harbor, and the Starks of Winterfell.
Rhaenyra's second son, Lucerys, travels to
Storm's End.
Prince Daemon leads the first attack of the
war on Harrenhal, which is conquered without
bloodshed.
The castellan, Ser Simon Strong, yields when
he sees Daemon's dragon.
This conquest leads to victories of the blacks
at the Burning Mill and Stone Hedge and allowed
the river lords, such as House Blackwood,
to gather at Harrenhal.
In the meantime, Jacaerys gains Lady Arryn
and the Lords Manderly, Borrell and Sunderland,
and Cregan Stark to Rhaenyra's cause, with
Cregan allying through the Pact of Ice and
Fire.
Towards the end of season 1, the first battle
between Targaryens and their dragons will
occur
which will set the dark tone for the rest
of the war, filled with blood, fire, revenge
and grief.
The Dance over Shipbreaker Bay.
Lucerys flies to Storm's End, arriving before
a gathering storm.
He finds Prince Aemond One-Eye and his dragon
Vhagar already present
who's there on his brother King Aegon's behalf
to win the Baratheon lord to his side.
Prince Aemond and Lucerys have bad blood even
prior to this as when they were younger, Lucerys
took out Aemond's eye with a dagger in a fight.
Aemond tries to provoke Lucerys into a fight,
insulting him, calling him a Strong bastard,
but Lucerys, sworn not to fight, refuses him.
He deliveres his message to Lord Borros Baratheon,
but is refused and told to leave.
Lord Baratheon prevents Aemond from attacking
his cousin in the castle, but allows for the
prince to follow him.
Mounted on his dragon, Aemond catches up with
Lucerys during a raging storm.
The fight between the two dragons does not
last long.
Vhagar, being five times bigger, has the advantage,
and Arrax falls broken.
Rhaenyra collapses when learning of Lucerys's
death.
Prince Daemon, at Harrenhal, sends a raven
to his wife, promising that her son's death
would be avenged.
Using one of his friends from King's Landing,
his former lover and current mistress of whisperers,
Mysaria who is played by an actress Sonoya
Mizuno, Daemon enlists the help of a former
serjeant in the City Watch, known now only
as Blood, and a rat-catcher from the Red Keep,
known now only as Cheese.
The two sneak into the Red Keep, using secret
tunnels and hidden doors, which brings them
into the Tower of the Hand.
There, Queen Alicent is bound and gagged,
and her bedmaid strangled.
When Queen Helaena (King Aegon's sister-wife)
and their three children appear, Blood and
Cheese close the doors and tell Helaena to
choose which of her sons will die.
Helaena reluctantly chooses Maelor because
he is younger, but Blood does the opposite
and kills the older Prince instead.
The two flee with the prince's head, leaving
the others unharmed and Daemon proves his
word to Rhaenyra, and they hit back at King
Aegon, a son for a son.
This is the season 1 finale and it sets the
tone for the upcoming seasons filled with
fire and blood, revenge and grief, deaths
of Targaryens, their dragons and their armies.
Ramin Djawadi, the composer of Game of Thrones
epic music is back to compose for all these
epic scenes in House of the Dragon.
If you like epic drama series filled not only
with epic battles between armies and dragons,
but also filled with court politics, betrayals
and everything that made you fall in love
with the world of Westeros in the first place,
then you are going to love this Game of Thrones
prequel.
House of the Dragon begins filming in about
one month and will premiere in 2022 on HBO.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs upand I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!